you
the
[Music]
good morning how did you sleep okay was
okay
what was it okay that kept feeling
something on top of my head it was an
accident
so this thing about Merida she doesn't
like it when I run my fingers through
her hair even though in that Lauryn Hill
song she enjoyed it very much but she
does not mix notice you're the only girl
that I know that doesn't like and in
your hair take off so quick toward the
place before we go here is the bedroom
it's actually very small but it has
everything that you need this is
basically a really fancy small studio we
have a single stove the washer here
sink and then I believe this right here
is I don't know what this is this is
like a dryer for the dishes and right
here my friends as you can see is a
glass mirror thing but if you move it
over is the bathroom amazing look at
that look how deep it is
it's literally made for you to sit in it
unlike American tubs where you have to
watch more long and then the water just
only goes up to your stomach or your
nipples this you can submerge the whole
body
[Music]
today we're going to have something
called spending my money is champagne
right here and usually what sin here is
the pancake and eggs and you could
choose a meat and I asked for cheese and
this thing is a sweet sauce I don't know
what it's made out of but it's really
good can't wait to try this
oh my god it's okay I'm not a really big
sweet Dyson when it comes to savory food
and if Taiwan is all about salty savory
foods and this is going to be the spot
for me it's exactly what it's like a
quesadilla yeah it's like a Taiwanese
quesadilla there's cheese in there
there's a there's a protein and then
there's like flour tortilla type of
mixture us awesome
Oh
[Music]
after we've got done having our
breakfast we are gonna be on our journey
so today we're gonna go on a food tour
and specifically Marielle did this for
me because she knows the biggest reason
why I travel is do II I think the
biggest way for me to understand the
cultures through their food and I know
that a lot of people are a little bit
scared to try new things but for some
reason for me when it comes to like a
country's food that's the way to get
into their heart so I'm excited to try
it out I'm ready to go and it's going to
be a fantastic day other than the fact
that I've had diarrhea already four
times we are using the public
transportation system here which I'm
pretty excited about if you guys
in the time one time one is actually
very similar to Penn but the biggest
image that I noticed here in number one
is that the subway system is a lot wider
there's a lot more room and it's not as
crammed that it is in Japan I think that
if we had public transportation where
I'm at right now in LA I would use it a
lot more but a super unreliable but this
place is a big difference
[Music]
it
[Music]
right now open I don't know it's like
they're still around or not but we found
one
the beans are really well roasted I put
there know for it's cheap it's so good
and how was that super good
oh really it's a lot more tomorrow the
smell of it works wrong
oh nice
that's interesting
it tastes literally like what it's
described so it tastes like Apple and it
also tastes like vinegar which I like
[Music]
hi guys so today we're gonna go through
something called a book tour basically
we're gonna have eight people maximum
and have a tour guide keeping letting us
try different kinds of going to do so
Taiwan is located in a subtropical area
so we grow a lot of tropical fruits so
we're gonna start off with no yet have
you guys had this before it's called I
go and I feel because when you open it
it has like a fleshy of Newt and with a
black seed inside so in the kind of
looks like an eyeball to hide the dragon
eyes where you guys can try it
[Music]
- you might like this red in the pink
guava is so good the texture of this one
is interesting because when you get the
pink guava then most people are used to
in specially when you're doing those
wine drinks this pink the plush is a lot
softer but this has like a pear light
texture and sweet and then on top of
that they add like the salty plum powder
on top of it and it's absolutely amazing
oh that's good it's so weird because
like Japanese mochi mochi Taiwanese
[ __ ] it's all different this one's a
lot more softer it's chewy but it's
actually very tender as like a very soft
cheese
[Music]
reading something called walk out to the
money's burger and then inside what we
have is two different kind of pork meat
there's a fatty kind of skinny kind and
what we're going to eat today is a mix
of it but towards the zr1 and inside
there's a meat cilantro and kind
about Bunner
it's like sweet and savory
sweet pork meat inside super good
oh yeah this is um definitely one of
those like perfect bites
[Music]
we just had the stinky tofu the level 13
it's not fried there's like some kind of
seaweed been with a molasses II soy
sauce pepper thing oh that smells great
first is fine and then later realize how
the aftertaste it smells so you bring
your mouth it's like Chinatown once you
know what it's a lot more stronger here
than it is back in LA I think that most
people are scared of it
my friend loved it he told me to try to
go you should try this and I walked in
the restaurant I like do somebody died
in here the tofu it's that you people
will say like always smells bad but it
ate it but it is exactly Mars
No
Oh
oh my god
look if you get drunk and you wake up in
the morning and your mouth was open the
whole night what are we about to have oh
yeah we're about to have a cold noodle
how many is cold noodle is basically a
dry noodle with it these egg noodle and
a half sesame sauce and garlic and
cucumber well the noodle texture it's a
little bit gooey hard drives and within
the peanut sauce peanut sesame sauce or
the garlic sauce is very strong it has a
very good fragrance this is pineapple
pump it's one of their special one [ __ ]
with it it looks a lot more interesting
than light cheap that's try but what was
it usually came here they want
okay refreshing you enjoyed the the
experience it was God it was super fun
the guy the Torah got Napoleon he was
super great telling us like the history
of it there's a lot of things I learned
a lot of food I had I paced myself so I
don't get plugged in so I'm really happy
right now
[Music]
next up we are off to go see Muriel's
host family one of two I was living with
them for about a year and a half and
they did really well to me they're
really nice especially when I broke my
foot
I couldn't take shower I couldn't cook I
couldn't do anything and the grandma was
like a superwoman she did everything she
took care of me she cooked she clean up
my place very nice family
[Music]
[Music]
our night is about to end today was a
very fun day um just from the food alone
that we ate from all the way till
getting to meet Mario's host family
which was really really awesome the cool
thing was that when we were there she
made us dinner setting Taiwan especially
in Taipei not a lot of people cooked at
home
cuz everything so convenient just to buy
out yeah mm-hmm so it's really rare to
see it homey you know oh really you buy
your food at home I mean outside today
yeah I'm too lazy yeah sometimes and
then cooking that's oh yeah that's right
so you just let the other people suffer
you know we weren't expecting to eat
dinner because we ate a crap ton of food
at or but if you guys know if you have
ever been in an Asian family you can't
just go there say you let your fool and
then not eat the food is super
disrespectful she put a lot of time love
and heart into it so I decided to shut
my mouth and just eat everything and the
great thing about that was that she's an
amazing cook so the food was out of this
world
so this is just the first day Taiwan
you've been amazing and I'm excited to
see what's the store tomorrow
[Music]